جاك سوليفان اول وارفع شخصيه سياسيه
امريكيه يلتقي اقطاب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده
الموصوفه بالاكثر تطرفا سياسيا ودينيا
ياتي مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي وفق
مصادر امريكيه موثوقه حاملا رساله تحذير
لحكومه
من مغبه اتخاذ اي خطوات من شانها القضاء
على رؤيه الدولتين وتقويض السلطه
الفلسطينيه وان
ظهر الضيف والمضيف امام كاميرات الصحفيين
بتصريحات وديه ودبلوماسيه
قضايا الامن القومي في فرص السلامه
ملتزمه بدعم اسرائيل بشكل قوي وهذا التزام
متجذر في التاريخ
والقيم المشتركه طرحت اجنده وسعه لنا
واتفق معكم ان علينا الحديث عن كافه
التحديات المشتركه نجحت الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه ولو مؤقتا في تجميد مناقشه خطه
لبناء مئه وحده الاستيطانيه في مستوطنه
نفتسيون في القدس المحتله كي لا يلقي ذلك
بظلاله على زياره سوليفان لكنه يبقى امرا
متواضعا حيال مطالب الفلسطينيين التي
استمع اليها الضيف الامريكي
ضروره ممارسه الضغط امريكي حقيقي لوقف
جميع الاجراءات احاديه الجانب غير
القانونيه وفي مقدمتها الاستيطان
واقتحامات المناطق الفلسطينيه والاعدامات
الميدانيه وهدم المنازل وتهويد القدس
والمقدسات وايضا ضروره بذل جهد امريكي
حقيقي من اجل استعاده الافق السياسي لحال
الصراع وياتي سوليفان لتبديد المخاوف التي
تعتري واشنطن من خطوات اسرائيليه لتوسيع
الاستيطان وضم فاضين في المناطق المصنفه
جيم في الضفه الغربيه المحتله الى جانب
التاكد من ان حكومه اليمين لن تفاجئ
الاداره الامريكيه باي تحرك عسكري بشان
ملف ايران النووي مع تعثر التوصل اتفاق
جديد مع طهرا
لا يحمل جاكسون في جعبته ايا خطه امريكيه
لاطلاق عمليه سياسيه جديده لكنه يسعى كما
يبدو الى نزع فتيل اي تصعيد محتمل في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله ووقف اجراءات
اسرائيليه قد تفجر الموقف برمته
الجزيره القدس المحتله